eight and music's biggest names waking
up with some new bling on their mantels
today
the 63rd grammy awards were last night
at the staples center in l.a
probably one of the most talked about
moments of the night was about queen bee
beyonce won not one not two not three
but
four grammy awards her win for best r b
performance for her album black parade
marked her 28th grammy she is now the
most
decorated woman in grammy history
i believe it's my job and all of our
jobs to reflect the times
and it's been such a difficult time so i
wanted
to uplift encourage celebrate all of the
beautiful black queens and kings that
continue to inspire me and
inspire the whole world well some of the
other highlights
taylor swift won album of the year for
folklore she's now the first female
artist to win that award
three times billy eilish won record of
the year for the second time for all i
ever wanted
megan the stallion took home three
grammys including best new artist
and there was plenty of social
distancing and coveted protocols last
night
and yeah no live audience also in a
grammy's first
employees from smaller music venues that
were hit hard by the pandemic
presented awards last night they did a
great background on those venues
and then the folks actually got to come
up on stage and present the awards
so thought that was really a nice moment
it was
i'll go ahead and say i was surprised
though with all the regulations and
restrictions
i would have thought the show would have
gone faster but i think it actually just
finished
it was a long shot it was good bruno
mars was so
good his voice is unbelievable that
little richard thing that he did
unbelievable yes that was fun yeah that
was a good moment taylor swift did her
three new songs so
lots of good stuff last night i think a
lot of people enjoyed the performances i
love the grammys it's full of good
music which is what it should be